welcome to this video against playing a
blitz game against born in bc what
exactly does bc mean and the sound text
ok we have a semi sloth type of position
he's playing with Bishop e7 though this
is a somewhat ancient way to to go about
things solid but also a bit passive mmm
Queen a five it's a somewhat uncommon
form with the Cambridge Springs I mean
94 he cannot play a c7 hang so what is
he doing h6 on I don't understand it ok
many many ways to play this prevents
Bishop before maybe he wants to go h6
Bishop h4 h g5 hmm it looks very strange
though ok here i can simply tank right
no I bishop on g hive is protected by
the night there are no no tricks ok to
age form yeah I guess keeping keeping
the pin keeping the pin your life that's
we're just the Queen on h5 in a Queens
gambit declined that's funny ok it does
not have many squares really not can go
to a five back maybe I can just play you
for here or not
now if five are threatened and he cannot
do that can take f6 take what can also
go to g3 yes also good or be should be
to learn okay but this this looks very
good getting gay getting into this
diagonal so I'm setting up this is very
awkward pin yeah what are you doing
after Bishop e2 or is there or do you
five already now this is strong it just
runs 95 and the Queen where should it go
there is really no pain no good square
okay if I take it on e5 he needs to take
with the bishop Knight takes Knight
takes then f4 f4 f5 Jim that that's
really overwhelming night h42 f5f is
also very good
I hard to say it's both both strong the
only thing that that irritates me is
that I'm not winning any material
directly or I'm miscalculating terribly
can kind of course be possible I can
actually also think about taking
everything off and roop the aid but my
FF is really the most logical booth
pushing in the night away okay so f 5m
and you must go to 2h7 probably Queen
Queen Nia this looks strange and now
what now Bishop look d3 or what happens
after h3 by the way 95
now the queen is very close to being
trapped on earth maybe we start with
this I'm getting down on time and I
definitely don't want to lose this game
after after this funny funny play ok
King h2 and tending g three runs into 94
check which is not very very nice Queen
Queen D to D for maybe yeah on on III
Bishop d3 something like that quindi
force in itself the problem the night
does not have any squares yeah
retreating theoretically speaking or
covering but that's not really good
Queen d6 also possible
yeah keep it simple Jack let's win the
piece of other Queen there was a piece
lost highway resigned it was a very
strange play and I probably didn't even
use it the best possible way it really
feels like I should should win a piece
or something directly but I didn't find
it Bishop d3 is the best and Bishop e2
is also the best okay and now taking
take take take and now the computer stop
fish is giving rook d 6 plus 3 look t6 I
don't understand the move
look d6 night ed 721 yeah of course why
this overwhelming after up t6 but not
quite sure exactly what it is doing ok
where this census also shouldn't
shouldn't be any bad yeah it's a similar
strength and now look at these three
years given as best but ok this should
at least keep a very good edge yeah plus
two still yanti it has just wins apiece
night eh five losses apiece he must play
this which is of course passive but but
still keeps everything together yeah
here black can hang on it's it's it's
uncomfortable but you can hang on look
him when the third-ranked was stronger
him here group d three this being one
important point winning a piece okay
thanks for watching